[Music]
the question isn't about whether dark
matter exists or not what's going on is
when we measure gravity in the universe
the the collective gravity of the stars
the planets the moon's the gas clouds
the black holes the the whole galaxies
when we do this 85 percent has no known
origin so it's not a matter of whether
dark matter exists or not
it's a measurement period now the dark
matter is not even what we should be
calling it because that implies that
it's matter it implies we know something
about it that we actually don't so a
more precise labeling for it would be
dark gravity now if I called it dark
gravity oh you're gonna say does dark
gravity really exist I say yeah cuz 85%
of the gravity has no known origin there
it is let's figure out what's causing it
the fact that the word matter got into
that word is forcing people to I have
another idea I bet it's not matter it
could be something else we're
overreacting to a label that overstates
our actual insights or knowledge into
what it is we're describing and then I
just joke we should just call it Fred
Fred or Wilma something where there is
no reference to what we think it is
because in fact we have no idea so
here's how you actually measure the
stuff in a galaxy which is the smallest
aggregation of matter where dark matter
manifests so you look how fast it's
rotating and we know from laws of
gravity first laid down by Johannes
Kepler and then modify then enhanced and
given further detail and deeper
understanding by Isaac Newton you write
down these equations say oh look how
fast it's rotating
you invoke that rotation rate in the
equation and out the other side says how
much gravity how much mass should be
there attracting you and the more mass
that's there the faster we expect you to
be orbiting that kind of makes sense so
when you do this calculation on a
galactic scale we get vastly more mass
attracting you then we actually can
detect I'm adding up stars gas clouds
moons planets black holes add it all up
it's a fraction of what we know is
attracting you in this orbit and we
cannot detect the rest and so we hand at
this title dark matter understandably I
suppose but it implies that we know that
it's matter but we don't we know we
can't detect it in any known way and we
know it has gravity so it really should
be called dark gravity I think the
over-under on what dark matter might be
today I think we're all kind of leaning
towards a family of particles subatomic
particles that have hardly any ability
to interact with the particles we have
come to know and love quote ordinary
matter and that would make it matter
dark matter as we've all been describing
it and it's not a weird thing that you
could have a particle that doesn't
interact with our particles within our
own family of particles there are
examples where the interaction is very
weak or non-existence you might have
heard of neutrinos this is a ghost-like
particle that permeates the universe and
hardly interacts with familiar matter at
all yet it is part of our family of
particles that we know exist and that we
can detect and interact with so if that
can if we can have an elusive particle
it's part of our own familiar family of
particles it's not much of a stretch to
think of a whole other category of
particles weird none of them give a
rat's ass about the rest of us and they
just pass right through us as though
we're not even there now here's what's
interesting about dark matter we know it
doesn't interact with us except
gravitationally by the way what do I
mean by interact does it bind and make
atoms and molecules and solid objects
no it does not interact with us in any
important known way but it also doesn't
interact with itself that's what's
interesting so if it interacted with
itself you can imagine finding dark
matter planets dark matter galaxies
because to interact with yourself is
what allows you to accumulate and have a
concentration of matter in one place
versus another these are the atomic
bonds and the molecular bonds that
create solid objects and if particles do
not interact with one another they just
pass through you just have this zone of
mass not really doing anything
interesting so dark matter not only
doesn't interact with us it doesn't
interact with itself and that's why when
we find dark matter across the universe
its varies diffusely spread out it's
it's like over here it's not in this one
spot and look at this concentration no
that's not how that works an example of
this you know what is a rock it's an
it's a collection of atoms and molecules
that are stuck together by
electromagnetic forces we don't think of
them that way
we just think of them as rocks but they
are held together by forces on the
atomic and molecular scale and they bind
together and then we get what we call
this solid object called a rock
if those forces did
work on you as a particle you have no
occasion to bind with any other particle
you have no occasion you have no
ambitions of ever becoming a solid
object it's a different kind of world
that would be we would not expect that
world to have life as we know it because
life requires an assembly of molecules
to turn it into some separate entity
distinct from everything else that then
has fascinating chemical properties that
we call life
[Music]